[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Siebers
in allen guten Abend Shabbat Shalom
grüßten sie in Jerusalem wo sie sich
gerade zum Gebet versammelt hatten als
plötzlich Schüsse fielen israelische
Rettungsdienste sprechen jetzt von
mindestens sieben Toten und vielen
Verletzten das sind die ersten Bilder
heute Abend aus der Gegend rund um eine
Synagoge im Osten von Jerusalem im von
jüdischen Siedlern bewohnten Viertel
Nähe Jakob
Michael Beverungen ist unser Israel
Korrespondent guten Abend Michael was
ist denn zu den Hintergründen dieser Tat
aktuell bekannt
also im Moment überschlagen sich die
Nachrichten noch und vieles von dem was
ich jetzt sage kann noch nicht unbedingt
als gesichert gelten sicher ist leider
dass sie Menschen gestorben sind der
achte ist der Attentäter selber der
getötet worden ist am Anfang gab es
Nachrichten über seine Identität es ist
aber inzwischen wieder in Zweifel
gezogen worden über den theatergang ist
so viel bekannt dass der Attentäter
wahrscheinlich in einem Fahrzeug in
diese Synagoge im Osten von Jerusalem
gefahren ist mit einer Pistole wohl in
die Synagoge eingedrungen ist auf die
Besucher die gerade die Synagoge
verlassen wollten gefeiert haben er soll
sogar manche geschubst zurückgeschossen
haben damit sie nicht fliehen konnten
anschließend ist er selber in einem Auto
geflohen und dann aber nach kurzer Zeit
von der Polizei gestoppt worden und
selbst erschossen worden im Moment ist
gerade Premierministerin ja auch vor Ort
eingetroffen der nationale
Sicherheitsminister der rechtsextreme
itama Ben wird ist auch schon seit
einiger Zeit da von ihnen gibt es noch
keine möglichen Reaktionen die Hamas hat
reagiert auch der islamische Gerhard die
beiden
Terrororganisationen haben gesagt das
sei die Rache für das was gestern in
Genin passiert ist wo es eben bei einer
Razzia zu vielen vielen getöteten
Palästinenser gekommen ist
die Lage in Israel und dem
patiensergebieten was ist ja gerade
schon kurz angesprochen ist ja generell
wieder ausgesprochen angespannt
vielleicht kannst du uns kurz die
Entwicklung schildern und auch vor allem
was jetzt zu befürchten steht
naja das ist die seit langem seit Wochen
befürchtete Eskalation der Gewalt die
Stimmung ist in den letzten Wochen auch
mit dieser neuen rechtsgerichteten
Regierung feines jeder geworden von
beiden Seiten das heißt nicht zwingend
das ist dieser Gewalt kommen musste
Einsätze wie gestern den Genie wo die
israelische Armee Razzien durchführt
Terroristen sucht die hat es auch mit
der letzten Regierung dutzendfach
gegeben auch da gab es sehr sehr viele
Tote gestern war es nun ein besonders
trauriger Tag wo acht militante Kämpfer
getötet worden sind und eine völlig
Unbeteiligte Zivilistin und das hat
natürlich
für großes Entsetzen gesorgt die Hamas
hat Rache geschworen offenbar hat es
diese Rache heute gegeben ob das jetzt
der Täter mit der Hamas direkt in
Verbindung steht und das ist noch unklar
mal wenn hat vor Ort gesagt wir müssen
uns jetzt als Regierung kümmern wir
müssen re so kann es nicht weitergehen
das lässt allerdings aus dem Munde eines
rechtsextremen polizeiministers nichts
Gutes für die Zukunft erwarten aber es
gibt noch keine weiteren Reaktionen nur
eine weitere Eskalation ist eher zu
befürchten unser israel hat Michael
Beverungen vielen Dank nach Tel Aviv
und damit zu uns hier nach Deutschland
Olaf Scholz allein zu Haus dieser
Eindruck konnte sich einstellen in den
letzten Wochen weil nicht nur laute
Stimmen aus der eigenen Koalition im
Parlament und Talkshows sondern auch die
größte Oppositionspartei den Kanzler
drängten endlich Kampfpanzer zu liefern
in die Ukraine Scholz zögerte lange und
es zeigt sich er passt da ganz gut zu
den von ihm regierten das brandneue ZDF
Politbarometer belegt eine gespaltene
Haltung bei den deutschen und einen
riesengroßen Ost-West-Unterschied die
Zustimmung zur leopardlieferungen wächst
aber es gibt auch viele die sie strikt
Ableben Hintergrund und Stimmen dazu hat
Christiane Hoffmann
für Frieden gehen Sie auf die Straße
wollen ein Ende des Krieges in der
Ukraine einige Dutzend Menschen sind
dafür fürs Brandenburger Tor gekommen
für sie ist klar mit der jetzigen
Politik der Lieferung von schweren
Waffen und Panzern wird Frieden nicht
erreicht sondern das Gegenteil
Waffen beenden diesen Krieg nicht
sondern verschärfen ihn nur ich glaube
dass das ein Putin sich nicht besiegen
lässt ich habe Angst vor einem Atomkrieg
ich habe Angst vor der Eskalation wo ist
denn die Diplomatie welche
diplomatischen Anstrengungen haben wir
denn unternommen sorgen die vielleicht
viele Teilen doch wie soll ein
imperialistisches Regime wie Russland
eingedämmt werden dass die Existenz
eines souveränen Staates in Frage stellt
Verunsicherung die auch das ZDF
Politbarometer widerspiegelt danach
halten 54% der Bevölkerung die Lieferung
von Leopard 2 Panzern für richtig 38%
sind dagegen allerdings herrscht ein
großer Unterschied zwischen Ost und
Westdeutschland während dem Westen 59%
für die Lieferung sind hält eine fast
gleich große Mehrheit im Osten diese für
falsch
es ist aus meiner Sicht auch nicht zu
akzeptieren dass die Bundesregierung
nicht erklärt was sie eigentlich vorhat
wir haben eine sicherheits- und
Verteidigungsstrategie gehabt über 70
Jahre Bundesrepublik Deutschland jetzt
wird innerhalb von Wochen und Monaten
werden die Dinge beiseite geschoben es
gibt keine neue Strategie wir sind nur
noch getriebene wo endet das Ganze der
Regierung fehlt der Kompass und Respekt
vor der Geschichte kritisiert Kretschmer
in seinen Worten halt wieder was viele
Ostdeutsche wohl bewegt eine stärkere
Angst vor direkten Folgen von Putins
Krieg so sehen es konfliktforscher wir
haben im Osten eine viel stärkere Nähe
nach Osteuropa auch in der Nähe zu
Russland da gibt es auch soziale
Beziehungen Bindung zum zweiten über
Jahre hat ist der Rechtspopulismus stark
geworden der sich ja nun deutlich auf
die Pro russische Seite schlägt
außerdem verfange russische Propaganda
im Osten Meer Politik müsse dagegen
steuern sich besser erklären Erklärungen
brauchen Thomas Gottwald und seine
Helfer aus Nürnberg nicht der
Familienvater ist gerade aus der Ukraine
zurückgekehrt zum siebten Mal hat er
Hilfsgüter hingebracht und bei
levraketen Beschuss erlebt also
grundsätzlich bin ich gegenkrieg aber
die Notwendigkeit macht es gerade leider
notwendig dass man Panzer liefert was
wollen wir sonst machen sondern die
Ukraine im Stich lassen sie ausbluten
lassen egal ob ein mobiles Heizkraftwerk
oder eben Waffen die Hilfe des Westens
gebe den Ukrainern Hoffnung so Gottwald
und lasse sie im Krieg durchhalten
ja und dann gibt es noch die große Frage
wie es mit der Bundeswehr weitergeht
deren ohnehin nicht üppiger Panzer
Bestand mit der Lieferung gen Ukraine ja
weiter schmilzt der neue
Verteidigungsminister lässt jetzt im
Interview mit der Süddeutschen Zeitung
durchblicken das aus seiner Sicht weder
die 100 Milliarden sonderschulden für
die Armee noch sein aktueller Jahresetat
von 50 Milliarden reichen werden und der
Nachschub ein echtes Problem ist
und noch etwas steht jetzt im Raum
nämlich die Forderung aus der Ukraine
nach Kampf Flugzeugen klare Ablehnung
dazu vom Bundeskanzler die USA und
Frankreich sehen das offenbar nicht ganz
so streng der stellvertretende nationale
Sicherheitsberater von Präsident Joe
Biden sagt man habe kein bestimmtes
Waffensystem ausgeschlossen mehr dazu
von Jürgen Kehl
russische Kampfjets präsentiert von der
Kreml Propaganda Einsatz über der
Ukraine kein Gegner in sich Raketen
werden abgefeuert mit westlichen Jets
etwa mit der amerikanischen F16 würde
die Ukraine gerne bald zurückschlagen
unrealistisch sagen viele Experten
Pilotenausbildung Logistik sehr
kompliziert
mit westlichen Kampfflugzeugen könnte
die Ukraine sicher aus dem Stegreif erst
mal nichts anfangen aber es ist ja auch
die mit 29 im Gespräch mit der mit 29
ist die Ukraine natürlich sehr gut
vertraut die Pilotin und Piloten Wissen
ähm sich Wissen des Flugzeug zu bedienen
es gibt entsprechende Logistik die
Ersatzteile sind da und so weiter und so
fort Bulgarien und vor allem Polen
könnten die Mick Jäger liefern aus alten
DDR-Beständen deshalb müssten auch hier
die Deutschen ihre Erlaubnis geben ein
Problem die Flieger bräuchten in der
Ukraine auch sichere Flughäfen können
die Basen überhaupt geschützt werden
gegen konzentrierte russische
Luftangriffe denn die operationsfreiheit
für die ukrainische Luftwaffe besteht ja
nur eine ganz gering es ist richtig das
Russland ist nicht geschafft hat die
Luft Herrschaft zu gewinnen aber die
Luft Überlegenheit haben sie halt immer
noch im dombas halten die Ukraine die
Stellung Bilder direkt von der Front von
tschechischen Fernsehen neue Munition
ist gekommen neue Kampfflugzeuge aus dem
Westen die Entlastung bringen könnten
sind wohl erstmal nicht in Sicht
ich glaube im Moment will man zunächst
herausfinden wie die Ukraine mit den
Panzern Vorankommen Jets werden
sicherlich in den kommenden Rammstein
Gesprächen auf der Agenda sein oder
Druck wird steigen aber ich würde nicht
mit einer schnellen Entscheidung rechnen
rund um das Städtchen wurde da am
Donbass werden also sobald keine neuen
Jets auf ukrainischer Seite kämpfen vor
einer Woche noch kam die Soldaten von
der Front hierher um sich auszuruhen
jetzt liegt der Ort unter russischen
Dauerbeschuss ein neuer Albtraum einer
von sehr vielen
die russischen Truppen die uns hier
befreit haben führen jetzt Krieg in der
Ukraine warum
das ist die verständnislose Frage von
einer die unvorstellbares grauen gesehen
hat Jesus ist 89 Jahre alt sie hat
Auschwitz überlebt sie sprach dort heute
bei der Gedenkfeier zum 78 jahrestag der
Befreiung des früheren deutschen
Konzentrationslagers im Deutschen
Bundestag sprach dessen Präsidentin mich
erschüttert dass auch Überlebende des
Holocaust durch die gegenwärtigen
russischen Angriffe auf die Ukraine
getötet wurden
Deutschland erinnert heute an die Opfer
des Nationalsozialismus im Mittelpunkt
zum ersten Mal all die die wegen ihrer
sexuellen Orientierung oder Identität
verfolgt wurden Stefanie gagasch am Ende
seines Lebens vier Jahre vor dem Tod
fehlen in Karl gorats Album viele Fotos
Erinnerungen die er nicht mehr behalten
wollte an die Zeit während des
Nazi-Regimes und danach den gorat warum
muss sexuell lange eine Straftat
ist für mich Vergangenheit und aus im
Bundestag bekam gorat heute eine Stimme
der Schauspieler Jannik Schümann der
selbst schwul ist gab sie lieber
kaigorath
eigentlich solltest Du hier stehen und
berichten
du bist alt geworden 90 Jahre alt
aber es hat nicht gereicht
2003 im Jahr deines Todes wollte nur
wenige Menschen Geschichten wieder ein
hören am heutigen Holocaust-Gedenktag
hörten viele seine Geschichte
stellvertretend für alle Homosexuellen
Opfer der Nazis zum ersten Mal wurde
speziell ihrer gedacht sie waren
Zehntausende für unsere
Erinnerungskultur ist es wichtig dass
wir die Geschichten aller verfolgten
erzählen ihr Unrecht sichtbar machen ihr
Leid anerkennen
1935 verschärfen die Nationalsozialisten
den Paragraph 175 der Unzucht zwischen
Männern bestraft gorat wird mehrmals
verhaftet kommt in das KZ Neuengamme
später nach Auschwitz Vernichtungslager
vor allem für Juden am 27 januar 1945
wird das Lager von der Roten Armee
befreit gorat kommt auf einen Transport
zurück Richtung Westen und überlebt nur
knapp in deinen Worten
am 8 mai 1945 war ich an Ruhe erkrankt
und fast schon tot ein französischer
Arzt hat mich aus einem Berg von Leichen
gezogen und wieder hochgepeppt doch mit
dem Fall der Nazi-Diktatur ist gorats
Leid nicht vorbei etwas das heute im
Bundestag besonders berührte schon im
März 1946 wirst du erneut verhaftet und
im September wegen schwerer Unzucht
unter Männern nach Paragraph 175 zu fünf
Jahren Zuchthaus verurteilt
zu deinem Entsetzen empfängt Dich im
Gerichtssaal derselbe Richter der dich
schon einmal verurteilt hat mit den
Worten sie sind ja schon wieder hier
denn der Straftatbestand und sucht unter
Männern Bestand weiter aus heutiger
Sicht klingt es unglaublich erst 1994
wurde der Paragraph 175 vollständig
gestrichen und es dauerte noch einmal
viele Jahre bis alle Urteile aufgehoben
wurden Cargo hat starb 2003 Battle Arm
nach seinen Verurteilungen wegen
Homosexualität fand er auch im befreiten
Deutschland keine Arbeit mehr
[Musik]
ein wichtiger Tag im Parlament und für
dieses Land
Hannah du hast jetzt den
Nachrichtenüberblick ja bis zu 700
Menschen haben gestern Abend vor dem
kreistagsgebäude in Grevesmühlen in
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern gegen eine
geplante Flüchtlingsunterkunft
protestiert darunter laut Polizei auch
Rechtsextreme und Reichsbürger ein Teil
versuchte sich Zutritt zu dem Gebäude zu
verschaffen in dem gerade der Bau der
Unterkunft beschlossen wurde ein
Großaufgebot der Polizei konnte das
Eindringen verhindern mehrere
Strafverfahren wurden eingeleitet unter
anderem wegen schwerem Hausfriedensbruch
nach langem Ringen haben sich Bund und
Länder auf einen Starttermin für das 49
euro-ticket geeinigt und zwar zum ersten
Mai das gab der Vorsitzende der
Verkehrsministerkonferenz Krischer
bekannt die deutschlandweit gültige
Monatskarte für den öffentlichen
Nahverkehr soll ab dem dritten April
verkauft werden die Einigung braucht
noch die Zustimmung der EU-Kommission
bei der ersten Debatte im Bundestag zu
geplanten Wahlrechtsreform gab es
zwischen der Ampelkoalition und der
Union keine Annäherung der Vorschlag der
Koalition sieht eine Abschaffung von
Überhang und Ausgleichsmandaten vor die
Union lehnt das ab sie schlug
stattdessen eine Reduzierung der
Wahlkreise vor SPD Grüne und FDP
bezeichneten dies als zu kompliziert und
nicht geeignet um die Regelgröße von 598
Abgeordneten im Bundestag zu erreichen
die Berliner Generalstaatsanwaltschaft
sieht keinen Anfangsverdacht für ein
strafbares Verhalten von
Bundesfinanzminister Lindner in
Verbindung mit einem Immobilienkredit
die Vorermittlungen hätten weder einen
ohnehin fernliegenden Anfangsverdacht
wegen Abgeordnetenbestechung noch wegen
Vorteilsannahme ergeben die Behörde war
tätig geworden weil Lindner ein Grußwort
für eine Bank gehalten hatte von der er
danach einen privaten Kredit bekam
das Schlimmste wäre wenn sie in
Vergessenheit geraten wenn ihr Schicksal
keine Schlagzeilen mehr macht wenn
Regierung und Polizei im Iran davon
ausgehen könnten dass es der Welt egal
wird wie brutal sie Vorgehen gegen all
die die mit ihrem Regime nicht
einverstanden sind es sollen seit Beginn
der Protestwelle 20.000 Menschen
festgenommen worden sein
340 von ihnen und es werden immer mehr
haben jetzt prominente Paten die sitzen
im Bundestag Landtagen und dem
Europaparlament und sie wollen zeigen
ihr seid nicht allein da ist eine
bemerkenswerte Bewegung entstanden quer
über alle Parteigrenzen hinweg dieser
Jani und Kamera safariam berichten
iranische Demonstranten ihn wurde
gezielt in die Augen geschossen
von den Sicherheitskräften
täglich willkürliche Übergriffe gegen
Frauen die Gewalt auf den Straßen bleibt
doch es kommen immer weniger Bilder aus
Iran
deswegen engagieren sich führende
Politiker Deutschlands jetzt
höchstpersönlich und zwar als Paten für
festgenommene revolutionäre
SPD-Chef laskingbeil setzt sich für die
29-Jährige Studentin Askari ein sie
sitzt wegen angeblicher Propaganda gegen
das Regime in Haft
als Vorsitzender der SPD und als
Abgeordneter des Deutschen Bundestages
habe ich deswegen die Patenschaft für
Summer nee übernommen sie muss
unverzüglich freigelassen werden und mit
ihr all die anderen die unrechtmäßig
inhaftiert sind all die anderen die
mutig protestiert haben
parteiübergreifende Solidarität auch
Oppositionsführer März hat wieder
SPD-Chef dem iranischen Botschafter
einen Brief geschrieben er fordert darin
ein faires Verfahren für den Deutsch
iranischen Staatsbürger Jump side short
macht Schau macht droht die Todesstrafe
der Regimekritiker wurde auf einer
Auslandsreise nach Teheran entführt das
Staatsfernsehen zeigt sein erzwungenes
Geständnis und wirft ihm einen Anschlag
vor
was bewirken die Patenschaften wir sind
uns ziemlich sicher in unserer
Einschätzung dass das Regime in Teheran
ziemlich genau verfolgt wie die Welt
Öffentlichkeit auf diese Fälle reagiert
auch auf die Hinrichtungen reagiert wie
auch einzelne Personen und ihre
Schicksale
namentlich bekannt gemacht werden und
wir wollen diesem Regime ein permanentes
schlechtes Gewissen verschaffen
340 deutsche Abgeordnete haben bisher
politische Patenschaften übernommen sie
appellieren posten die Schicksale in den
sozialen Medien
die deutsch-iranische Aktivistin daniela
seperi hat die Patenschaften mit
organisiert können Sie Hinrichtungen
verhindern
eine Patenschaft ist keine Garantie
dafür dass jemand freigelassen wird oder
dass das Leben geschützt wird eine
Patenschaft ist ein zusätzliches
Instrument zum zivilgesellschaftlichen
Engagement politischen Druck und
Aufmerksamkeit und Öffentlichkeit zu
schaffen und jeder jede Preis für jede
Hinrichtung der Preis für jede Folter
wird uns Unermessliche steigen im Fall
des zum Tode verurteilten Mohammad robot
scheint der öffentliche Druck Erfolg
gebracht zu haben nach einem
Schauprozess stand die Hinrichtung des
22-Jährigen unmittelbar bevor seine
politische Partien atmet auf die
Hinrichtung ist vorerst ausgesetzt wir
haben jeden Tag gebangt um das Leben von
Mohammed Lou und sehr viel Druck erzeugt
auch öffentlichen Druck und wir waren
dann sehr erleichtert als vor einigen
Tagen die Nachricht kam dass der Vorwurf
des Mordes und die daraus resultierende
Hinrichtung jetzt noch mal vom Gericht
überprüft wird
die Menschen in ihrer an protestieren
weiter und Sie brauchen die
Aufmerksamkeit der freien Welt
Fragen zum Thema an den aus dem Iran
stammenden Generalsekretär der FDP er
ist selbst Pate nachher im heute-journal
Update
jetzt erstmal noch mal du Hanna
bundesweit fehlen tausende Lehrkräfte
die kultusministerinnen Minister der
Länder haben deshalb Vorschläge
vorgestellt die die Lage entspannen
sollen eine Expertenkommission empfiehlt
unter anderem das Pädagogen weniger ein
Teilzeit arbeiten sollten zudem müssten
Anreize geschaffen werden um Lehrkräfte
im Ruhestand zurückzugewinnen und auch
eine Erhöhung der Klassengröße zählt zu
den vorgeschlagenen Maßnahmen der
Lehrerverband kritisierte die Vorstöße
und warnt vor drohenden Burnouts
auch heute blieben in Deutschland wieder
Millionen Briefe und Pakete liegen die
Beschäftigten der Deutschen Post haben
ihre Waren ihren Warnstreik fortgesetzt
und erhöhen damit noch einmal ordentlich
den Druck auf ihren Arbeitgebern meint
bisher sind die Tarifverhandlungen
nämlich ziemlich festgefahren oder ja so
sieht's zumindest aus für die rund
160.000 Tarifbeschäftigten im Bereich
Post und Paket Deutschland werden 15%
mehr Lohn gefordert und um diesen
durchzusetzen haben heute laut
Gewerkschaft Verdi und 18.000
Beschäftigte gestreikt jedes sechste
Paket und jeder zehnte Brief sind
liegengeblieben Verdi verweist auf
gestiegene Gewinne in der Vergangenheit
die Post wiederum darauf dass sie Geld
für Investitionen braucht und
Arbeitsplätze sichern will in der
nächsten Tarifrunde ab 8 Februar will
der Konzern dann ein eigenes Angebot
vorlegen und bis dahin könnte mancher
Streik fortgesetzt werden
und dann lass uns noch einen Blick auf
den DAX werfen ein Plus von fast neun
Prozent in den ersten vier Wochen des
Jahres und das trotz aller Krisen ja so
ist es also diese Krisen scheint
zumindest im Januar fast vergessen zu
sein denn dieser fulminante Jahresstart
am deutschen Aktienmarkt der ist einer
der besten in der Geschichte des DAX am
Ende der Woche steht er bei
15.150 Punkten Gründe für diesen
Optimismus gibt es einige die
Konjunkturdaten sind besser als gedacht
und die Energiepreise haben sich etwas
entspannt nächste Woche könnte es dann
hier am Parkett durchaus dynamisch
werden eine Reihe von Unternehmenszahlen
stehen an und die Notenbanken
entscheiden über die Leitzinsen diese
könnten nun etwas moderater steigen denn
die Inflation dürfte ihren Höhepunkt
überschritten haben vielen Dank Sina
nach Frankfurt
zur Handball WM nach dem Viertelfinale
aus haben die deutschen Handballer zum
Auftakt der Platzierungsrunde den ersten
Sieg eingefahren das Team von
Bundestrainer Gisler sonnengewann gegen
Ägypten knapp nach Verlängerung mit 35
zu 34 den entscheidenden Treffer
erzielte Julian Köster eine Minute vor
Schluss mit dem Sieg hat die DHB-Auswahl
weiter die Chance auf Rang 5 am Sonntag
geht es dann gegen Norwegen
ja und das war unser Freitag im
heute-journal und jetzt schließt sich
der Kreis wir haben ja vorhin in der
Sendung schon sehr interessante Zahlen
vom Politbarometer gehört jetzt bekommen
Sie alles im Detail von Matthias vorn
auf tschüss Ciao
guten Abend willkommen zum
Politbarometer niemals allein das ist
der Leitspruch des Bundeskanzlers wenn
es um heikle Waffenlieferungen an die
Ukraine geht
lange hat er die Entscheidung über die
Lieferung der Kampfpanzer vom Typ
Leopard 2 hinausgezögert damit ist es
Olaf Scholz wohl aber gelungen die USA
ebenfalls zur Lieferung von schweren
Kampfpanzern zu bewegen
zuletzt waren die Deutschen in dieser
Frage noch gespalten das hat sich jetzt
geändert
das Deutschland der Ukraine Kampfpanzer
vom Typ Leopard 2 liefern will finden
54% richtig 38 Prozent nicht deutliche
Mehrheiten dafür gibt es unter den
Anhängern der Regierungsparteien und der
Union vor allem die Anhänger der AFD
lehnen die Leopard 2 Lieferungen an die
Ukraine deutlich ab auch die meisten
Anhänger der Linken sind dagegen
die Zustimmung zur Lieferung der
Kampfpanzer ist zuletzt gestiegen
allerdings gehen die Meinungen dazu in
West- und Ostdeutschland auseinander
denn im Westen befürwortet eine Mehrheit
von 59 Prozent die Lieferung der
Kampfpanzer an die Ukraine nur ein
Drittel lehnt sie ab im Osten ist es
genau andersrum nur gut ein Drittel
stimmt zu eine Mehrheit von 57% lehnt
die Lieferung ab
im Osten ist auch die Sorge ausgeprägter
dass die Kampfpanzer Putin provozieren
könnten insgesamt glaubt knapp die
Hälfte der Deutschen dass ein Angriff
Russlands auf westliche Staaten mit der
Lieferung von Kampfpanzern
wahrscheinlicher wird genauso viele
glauben das aber nicht
die Ukraine ausreichend zu unterstützen
und gleichzeitig nicht selbst zur
Kriegspartei zu werden diese
Gratwanderung muss seit gut einer Woche
auch der neue Verteidigungsminister
Boris Pistorius Meister und dafür erhält
er eine Menge Vorschusslorbeeren
das Boris Pistorius seine Arbeit
gutmachen wird erwarten 68 Prozent aller
Befragten nur 8% meinen er wird sich
schlecht machen die Anhänger fast aller
Parteien sehen das mit deutlicher
Mehrheit so bei den Linken sagen das
immerhin noch 46 Prozent
zuletzt hat die Ampelkoalition ein
zerstrittenes Bild abgegeben trotzdem
glauben mehr als zwei Drittel der
Befragten dass die Regierung bis 2025
halten wird
wenn schon am Sonntag Bundestagswahl
wäre käme die SPD auf 21 Prozent plus
eins die cdu/csu unverändert auf 27 die
Grünen
19-2 die FDP unverändert 6% AFD 15 + 1
und die Linke weiterhin 6%
damit hätten weder die Ampel noch
Schwarz-Grün eine parlamentarische
Mehrheit knapp reichen würde es für eine
große Koalition und deutlich für einen
Jamaika Bündnis aus cdu/csu Grünen und
FDP
schauen wir auf unsere Top Ten also die
Bewertung der zehn wichtigsten
Politikerinnen und Politiker nach
Sympathie und Leistung auf der Skala von
+5 bis -5 bleibt Alice Weidel
Schlusslicht unverändert mit sehr
schlechten -2,7 Sarah Wagenknecht minus
0,8 leicht verschlechtert Platz 8
Friedrich Merz minus 0,2 verbessert
davor nennt sie fäser minus 0,1
unverändert Markus Söder ebenfalls minus
0,1 leicht verschlechtert
Platz 5 Christian Lindner mit 0,0 wieder
besser
Karl Lauterbach auch bei 0,0 aber
verschlechtert auf dem dritten Platz
Olaf Scholz 0,6 leicht verbessert Platz
2 hält Anna-Lena baerbock mit 0,8 ganz
vorne bleibt Robert Habeck 0,9 beide mit
leichten Einbußen
die Inflation geht zwar leicht zurück
bleibt aber weiter auf hohem Niveau
verständlich erscheint da vielen die
Forderungen nach deutlich höheren
Gehältern gerade sind die
Tarifverhandlungen im öffentlichen
Dienst angelaufen
dass die Forderung der Gewerkschaften
nach einer Erhöhung der Löhne und
Gehälter um 10,5 Prozent zu hoch ist
sagen 44 Prozent für 49 Prozent ist die
Forderung gerade richtig 4% meinen sie
ist noch zu niedrig
in Berlin läuft noch bis Sonntag die
Grüne Woche ein Thema über das dort
diskutiert wird das von
Landwirtschaftsminister Özdemir geplante
verpflichtende haltungslabel für
Schweinefleisch
strengere Vorschriften in der
Tierhaltung auch wenn dadurch Fleisch
Milch und Eier deutlich teurer werden
befürwortet eine klare Mehrheit von 79%
der Befragten nur 19% sind dagegen
die Wirklichkeit an der Supermarktkasse
könnte dann wieder ganz anders aussehen
das war unser Bericht über die Stimmung
im Land die Grafiken und alle
Informationen zu unseren Umfragen finden
Sie wie immer im ZDF textab Seite 165 in
der ZDF heute App und auf ZDF heute.de
wie die repräsentativen Umfragen der
Forschungsgruppe Wahlen Zustandekommen
Informationen zur Methodik und zu den
Qualitätsstandards finden Sie unter
politbarometer.zdf.de
vielen Dank für Ihr Interesse das
nächste reguläre Politbarometer gibt es
dann am 17 Februar ein Politbarometer
extra zur Wiederholungswahl in Berlin am
3 Februar nach dem Wetter geht es hier
weiter mit der heute-show in noch ein
entspannten Abend auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter ordnen wir das
Jahr 2022 mal ein klimatologisch gesehen
und das hier sind die wärmestreifen seit
1850 jeder Streifen ist ein Jahr und
wenn wir Richtung Gegenwart schauen
waren vor allem die letzten drei
Jahrzehnte besonders warm Temperatur
nimmt deutlich zu und das Jahr 2022
reiht sich in die wärmsten Jahre seit
1850 ein das sorgt für Extremwetter
Ereignisse weltweit derzeit ist es aber
relativ ruhig wir haben es mit einem
kleinen hoch zu tun was uns sogar etwas
Sonnenschein bringt morgen im
Tagesverlauf aber das Tief hier Richtung
Island das wandert dann am Montag in
unsere Richtung und bringt Sturm
Regenschauer und auch Gewitter mit sich
wir schauen in die kommende Nacht da
gibt's im Südosten kompakte Wolken mit
Schnee ansonsten nach Norden bildet sich
Nebel bei tief Zimmertemperaturen von -6
Grad nach Osten und zwei Grad im
Rhein-Main-Gebiet das wäre die
Temperatur spannen morgen letzte
Schneefälle Richtung Bayern ansonsten
Sonnenschein vor allem nach Westen bis
Richtung Berlin und das mit Temperaturen
von -4 Grad im Vogtland und fünf Grad in
Schleswig-Holstein kommenden Tage am
Sonntag wird es relativ ruhig sein bei
-2 bis 7 Grad über Montag geht's dann
zur Sache mit Sturm Schauern Schnee an
den Alpen ja und sogar Graupel Gewittern
und damit ein schöner Abend